hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about
th17 cells th17 cell is one
type of t helper cell or rather it's a
subpopulation of t helper cell
which are heavily involved against
fungal
infection and they are solely
responsible
for autoimmune disorders in this video
we'll talk about
how th17 cells develop and differentiate
what is the function of th17 cells and
how does th17 cells
takes part in the immune response so
let's begin
th17 cells plays a crucial role
against fungal infection such as candida
albiguns
now th17 cells are
unique because they secrete the cytokine
il-17 and thereby the name th17
is justified th cells
the t helper cells can get
differentiated
into several subpopulation depending
upon the cytokines that they encounter
for example th7 th cells can be
differentiated into th one subpopulation
which help to bring out the immune
response against intracellular pathogen
and th2 cells which help to
fight against extracellular pathogens
apart from these varieties
there is th17 cells which are solely
responsible
for cell-mediated immunity and defense
against
fungus there is another variety known as
t follicular cell which is important
for humoral immunity and they augment b
cell response and they are solely
present in the germinal center
so all of these subtypes of the t cells
can be formed
from the t helper cells depending upon
the cytokine
that is there now our discussion today
is on th17 cells and its function
so it turns out th cells get
differentiated
into th17 cells with the help of the
cytokines il-6
and tgf beta but the question is where
does these
cytokines come from it turns out these
cytokines
are actually derived from antigen
presenting cells such as macrophages and
dendritic cells
now when does macrophage or dendritic
cell secrete this kind of cytokine
it's simply when macrophage or dendritic
cell encounters
fungal proteins and they recognize a
fungal protein with the help of a toll
like receptor
which is a pattern recognition receptor
this store like receptor too
helps to kind of
identify fungal proteins and thereby
leads to activatory signals which
further
leads to production of il-6 or tgf beta
which turns out to be the key cytokines
for th17 cell differentiation
now th17 cell differentiation is
controlled by several
master regulators one of them the most
important of them
is the ror gamma so whenever ta
whenever il6 or tgf beta is bound to the
specific receptors on the t helper cell
they lead to a signaling
and this signaling ultimately express
the master regulator gene ror gamma t
expression of ror gamma t leads to
a specific molecular network which
help these th cell to be differentiated
into a th17 subpopulation
th17 subpopulation turns out to be
involved
in several autoimmune diseases and in
ror gamma t knockout mouse
which in which the differentiation of
ti-17
should not happen those kind of mouse
lines
shows increased susceptibility towards
fungal infection and that makes sense
because th17 cells
are actually involved in antifungal uh
responses but these
these same knockout mouse shows
less severity of experimental autoimmune
enzyme cephalitis
that means t7 th17 cells
are normally involved with autoimmune
response
and if you get rid of th17 cells the
severity of the autoimmune response
decreases th17 cells are
dominant inflammatory cells which are
associated with
chronic inflammatory bowel disease or
many other autoimmune diseases
they can secrete il-17 or il-22 these
are several cytokines
which can be associated with tissue
inflammation
now they are mainly found in mucosal
tissues of the intestinal lining
lungs and also in case of the
intes lungs and intestine now th17 cells
which are found in lungs and intestine
can
provide immunity against several
bacteria such as
salmonella typhimurium pseudomonas
originosa
etc now the exact mechanism of th17 cell
is not known and it is a subject of
ongoing research
so in future we hope to learn more about
th17 cells so if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share and subscribe thank you